channing tatum and zoe kravitz are
k-i-s-s-i-n-g on a yacht in italy that's
the dream
check out the duo sailing the high seas
in style chan leans in for a smooch
while they relax on the deck and another
pda moment this time the actor sweetly
pulling zoey in tightly yeah we gotta
channel zoe as catwoman here and say
meow
you got a lot of cats
everything about strays while pda for
this pair is rare they've let their love
flag fly while on a european getaway
last week paparazzi snapped the two
hugging and holding hands during a
romantic stroll truly happy to be here
zoe and channing first started dating
last fall and that was only after
entering a professional relationship she
definitely she's got a weird gift for
that uh she sees right through a lot of
people's stuff and really kind of just
who they are to her is really simple
like and she's one of the more
intentional people i've ever met in my
life yeah zoe called in the actor for a
part in her directorial debut a thriller
she co-wrote called [ __ ] island you
gave zoey some advice on it too is that
what you said to her like don't do both
yes
i just don't think you enjoy it like i
think i didn't enjoy i didn't get to
enjoy really directing i i think that
it's
you need twice the time if you're going
to be in the movie i'm absolutely not
starring in in that film i i don't i
it's hard enough to to act on on your
own i don't know how people do both so
um yeah i will not be in the movie i'll
just be directing it one thing at a time
and channing speaks from experience he
signed on for joey's project after
directing and starring in dog maybe just
take crazy down just like one
just one notch that's it maybe we could
get along
and if we get along maybe we could even
have some fun but back to [ __ ] island
we'll reportedly see chan play a tech
mogul who gets caught up with an
ambitious cocktail waitress it's a role
that shows the actor in a completely new
light so why were you shocked
that you were asked to play this part
when you were her first choice for the
film i definitely don't play any
one that i've ever played before in this
in this movie um i think
people call me for very specific things
and this is just a completely
categorically different thing and it was
it was
it was one like really awesome to like
to be thought of in that way that i
could do that and then also you know a
very specific
point of hers was just like look i i
really know that she really made or saw
me i guess i can tell you it's it's
incredible
i'm in awe she's doing better than reed
and i did on on our first movie with dog
i mean
geez we barely survived our first movie
and um and she's just killing it yeah
catwoman obviously clawed her way into
channing's heart
[Music]
check out the star stepping out for the
batman premiere earlier this year who
also got support from her stepdad jason
momoa jason and channing two of your
guys and your fam giving you a shout out
what does it mean to have them in your
corner giving you that support well you
know we're in new york tonight and i
live here i have a lot of friends and
family here tonight so i feel very lucky
to have a lot of people who love me here
you